and in ten days sold one point six
million dollars in merch is this zilean
beers thing what happened yeah what is
this okay so barstool just put a clinic
on marketing on how to do marketing
right okay so will tell me the story I
don't know I don't get what happened
barstool sports will dumb it down
barstool sports media company like ESPN
or bleacher report but
personality-driven
in the ESPN after three beers base yeah
it's just like comedy it's more it's
like SNL it's more comedy and fiction
than it is whatever journalism yeah yeah
sometimes it is some I mean everyone
small don't have something amazing but
ya know it's it's just a much like like
it's for the average man by the average
of manners what their tagline okay they
have a guy he's a camera guy and Henry's
a big fan so he knows to they have a guy
a camera guy named Dana Dana was getting
made fun of one day like 10 days ago for
drinking too many beers and he set a
line like he tweeted out and he said
some line like I'm just a guy who drinks
a zillion beers and he starts like
talking about zillion beers over the
course of a day and his boss Dave
Portnoy was like dude you're a cameraman
you're not a Content guy quit the
zillion beer stuff yeah try to stop
trying to make it a thing I'm trying to
make it thing and Dana goes Dave I bet
you I can sell like $30,000 worth of the
zillion dollar beer merch and Dave goes
if you do that I'll give you 10 grand or
something like that
they blew past it then after a few days
of this going back and forth it gets to
the point of if you sell a million
dollars with the merch in the next five
days I'll give you a hundred grand right
he has across that he got 1.5 million
and how long do you think that lasted so
he created a brand essentially on the
fly
Zoey Peters brand called zillion beers
and in ten days sold one point six
million dollars in merch and throughout
this process pretty much the way in
which they sold merch was pretty much
all Twitter and so I was watching it
like as a marketing person I was looking
Dana went from having a thousand
followers on Twitter to whatever he has
now maybe 150 thousand followers on
Twitter in 10 days and he would get into
Drott like draw like a fights like so
for example he
met this girl on Twitter and she flew
out and they started like talking about
how they're dating now even though they
just met and then the ex-boyfriend
starts tweeting at him and he's like all
right me and you we're gonna get in a
fight at rough and rowdy I put a hundred
grand online it's on that book that
became a storyline there's like a dozen
different story it's all just happening
like a weekend basically yeah and
everyone was following it in real time I
didn't go out on Valentine's Day because
I was just refreshing Twitter and just
like reading about all this
it was amazing yeah that is amazing I
saw it happening I didn't understand the
full backstory yeah I I saw it happening
I don't even drink beer and I bought
$150 worth of zillion beer Berg yeah
just out of respect for what was going
on it was great to support the cause
it's like a it's like a rowdy
Kickstarter that he did I love it yeah
and so I think the takeaway here is like
they barstool put on a clinic of like
how fast you can do stuff yeah
and people want to be a part of
something and so it's one thing to just
sell merch it's another thing to be a
part of something which is like oh my
god once it gets the momentum if we're
going for a million holy we're
gonna do it my boss bet against me
helped me beat the man I think it like
it just caught this wave of it wasn't
about the merch obviously like none of
it was about the merch it was about
putting it into Dave's face right oh you
doubted him we're all gonna get behind
him and this guy Dana the guy behind it
he's like a total bro but he seems like
a really good person and it was fun
watching him like be excited watching
him win yeah and people he put his venmo
out there and I voted him like 50 bucks
people ven mode of money collectively he
got like 3 grand and he went and blew it
all at a fancy restaurant it was funny
seeing like a redneck he at a steak
restaurant minute
[Music]